hello and welcome to this video I hope
this is working out I had a problem in
the video before with my one of my
neighbors suddenly hammering away what
they did but it was amazingly loud but
it stopped and I hope it's not coming up
again let's see what happens okay I've
got a ready style opening here with now
black having a wide choice of very
different options taking on c4 and let's
start again
Jesus okay I'm sorry about this is
probably quite irritating but I had this
time set aside for recording some video
so yeah I hope they don't continue for a
very long time
[Music]
with them by a transposition we went
into a Catalan and a closed catalan is
usually good news for white I have much
more space let's see what frankestein 68
has planned so it just takes on e4 this
is a very comfortable position for white
yeah you can go to each or see to both
moose make some sense not sure both is
good for white the basic problem is that
the bishop on c8 is not going to be
active ever problem okay
again sorry about the sounds I didn't
quite expect it to start again really
okay so we're trading trading this it's
um usually not such a brilliant idea to
trade when you've got more space but to
dark-squared bishop here are something
that I don't mind trading one thing is
that I've got an idea here to play on
the dark squares with c5 and this is
some probably going to happen quite soon
I just wonder I can even go Queeny five
in this position it's a bit uncommon but
that's probably not the best possible
choice okay now it's interesting to play
c5 I wanted to do it immediately but
this is probably not best it's possible
you can go CFRA via immediately it's an
excellent compensation I just wonder
even the me even before is a move
if I go Queen to e3 and intend to play
c5 it is probably not not the best way
to go I want to get in c5 maybe this way
I don't know I took too long for this I
mean I'm going to be better here pretty
much regardless and took a bit too long
to play this move so easing me he's
preparing c5 but okay it's so not going
to do it
can still not place e5d takes e5 I'm
covering the knight on e5 from from be
sorry in from b2 why is that working
okay anyway um
and let's go to d6 this is one of the
points of trading the dark squared
bishop I wanted to put the pawn to c5
and then bring the Knight to c4 this is
now materializing and it's not fun for
black I don't know maybe he won't take
on c5
oh it's very very awkward for black very
awkward maybe 85 Knight takes Knight
takes e5 something like that well it's
it's I'm going to win material here I
just wonder Bishop a6 is actually
actually on the cards okay so a 96 maybe
even
[Music]
this is also move maybe he's playing
Bishop a6 against it this could be
interesting if you hear I can take and
95 cod Quincy five big a 6 I have Knight
takes c6 now okay now how do we do this
what is a good square here see form on
[Music]
or queen F form just a queen F force
actually good young just trade Queens or
provoke a 5 now the difference is he
doesn't have ninety five anymore
yeah compared to going to to see form
immediately I Scott Rock deform I
overlooked that
hmm that'sthat's a bit stupid still have
a good very good position right I
overlooked that I've got a little bit of
play left
yeah those pawns should do the trick
and that these are really too quick am
just going to promote okay yeah the the
close Catalan is not much fun and if
black enters a somewhat substandard
version its its its gets very ugly
usually so this is still fairly normal
but now he started to play a couple of
strange move like rupee eight it's not
necessary a six you usually want to try
some be six here be six and potentially
Bishop a six white is better here but
this is giving a bit more counter play
at least these moves are just not
helping yeah I'm opening this and if you
just assume that white is going to play
the moves that I played and then you see
what did black do in the meantime
Ruki eight doesn't help a six doesn't
help and the problem is he has no way
ever to get see a doubt so we got this
now the trade and now then I think of it
it was probably a good idea to just play
c5 immediately just play it immediately
like it's going to come back I go here
and now this is this is coming and it's
it's dreadful yeah this is never moving
so this I now c5 was interesting but
here here in particular maybe I could
have done that you know this move if he
takes Knight c4 Queen e7 and then this I
looked at this a little bit but I
couldn't quite make my mind up I thought
this isn't that fantastic actually
[Music]
but now that I see and this is actually
good yeah I can do this and this and
then Bishop c6
Bishop c600 the engine points out that
there is a pinion okay okay I mean what
is better but comparing this to keeping
the tension I want to keep the tension
so this and before I am it's it's ugly
it's really ugly for blacks e5 Quincy
794 maybe not even the best move but it
keeps a huge advantage f5 and the engine
just wants to take yeah I thought Knight
takes e5 is still annoying I mean I saw
that I can move the Queen and I'm better
word and the engine just says its wins
okay hmm
yeah I saw that it's not that I didn't
see it but I thought that this isn't so
great but it is actually super clear I
am okay I mean what what is he doing he
answers this is killing it because
there's like everything hangs okay and
then Queen d4 isn't the best it is a
huge advantage but it's not decisive
yeah Bishop a6 would have been more
interesting I would have given the
exchange and I think this must be
excellent yeah I don't know King takes
maybe yeah that's true this hangs and
this hangs yeah it's also it's very good
for white but I could have just played
in a simpler way here takes Knight f6
Queen f4 and Quincy for now there's not
even 95 okay so Knight B seven wins that
is true Liam no this is a huge thing but
I think whatever I do it the the
advantage is very substantial you can
play the odds
sub-optimal move but it's still winning
it's just it's just too much if you see
yeah you don't see the diagram actually
I didn't really even give up much of an
advantage after I had it okay guys
thanks for watching